puis
il a 20 ans des cheveux dans le vent et
déjà toutes ses dents
il a 20 ans et confond le bon temps avec
les sentiments et 7 pas raisonnable mais
c'est bien agréable
d'avoir un fort secteur qui a le coeur
plus voltigeurs que moi ni la battant
des pulls à ras le cul qui serait avec
misc
épatant pire que je vient de s'offrir
pour qu'il soit sorti
et penser bassin dis-moi si l'une qu'à
l'instinct n'est pas que j'aime pas ça
mais mon docteur me déconnecte là il
avait fait un peu pâle hyper de faire
surtout qu'à cet âge à tous les
complexes viata chaque pas
j'ai chassé de mon vocabulaire
tous les petits mots qu'avait leur
parler de bijoux de fourrure de schiste
car il comprend à la plaisanterie
à côté de lui avec ses cheveux longs
mois génère de gaston coup le seul en
victime fitness vérifier même des
pantalons et le soir en cheville pendant
que l'une des pistes suivies des
bigoudis au bord du lit pendant six ans
à l'inter quand par hasard du talent de
ces affaires c'est pas de fond sur 20
c'est pour me dire qu'il a des courses à
faire dans les magasins
que je l'accompagnais ocapri amy st
montchoisi rhdp dans mail et ribambelle
de 4,7 à gogo
parents
et abritant des témoins